Hi, welcome back. In the last few
sessions, we've talked about value
investing, its glory in the 20th century
and its fading in the 21st century and
its allure to investors. In the next
few, I want to look at growth investing
in its various forms. And in this
particular session, I want to focus on
one variant of growth investing, which
is investing in small cap companies or
small companies. So, let's start by
defining what a growth investor is.
Again, we'll start with the conventional
and lazy definition. The conventional
and lazy definition is a growth investor
buys companies that are growing or even
more lazily buys companies that trade at
high PE ratios or high price to book
ratios. Implicit in that definition
seems to be the suggestion that growth
investors don't care about value. So,
I'm going to give you my generic
definition of a growth investor, which I
think is a lot more charitable to what
growth investors try to do. Growth
investors try to buy companies where
they think the value of growth is being
underestimated by the market. Let me
repeat that again. Growth investors buy
companies where they think the value of
growth is being underestimated by the
market. Put simply, both value investors
and growth investors care about value.
The question is where they where they
think they can find those bargains in
the market. using that financial balance
sheet I used to illustrate value
investing. The simple way to think about
growth investing is rather than focus on
assets in place, which is what value
investors do, growth investors believe
that their best shot at finding cheap
companies or mispriced companies, is
look at companies with the bulk of the
value comes from growth assets. That
markets for whatever reason make
mistakes about valuing those growth
assets and you can take advantage of
those. With that in place, let's talk
about the many phases of growth
investing. I'm going to start and spend
the bulk of this session talking about
investing in small cap companies. It's
true. It's true. Small cap companies
don't necessarily have to be growth
companies, but many people use it as a
shortcut to go with growth. We'll talk
about the logic of doing it, whether it
pays off and whether that payoff is
changing over time. We'll then move on
to investing in companies that have just
gone public or are planning to go
public. Investing in IPOs, initial
public offerings. Again, we look at the
allure, whether it pays off and what the
what the limitations might be. We'll
then bring in something we saw with
value investing screening for cheap
growth stocks. Here we will look at the
variance, the types of screens people
use to find cheap growth stocks. And
we'll close off as we did the value
investing section by looking at activist
investors but activist investors in the
growth space. You might not have heard
of these but you probably heard of them
with a different name. Venture capital
is after all investing in growth and
being activists. You try to change the
companies and modify them after you've
invested in them. So let's start with
small cap investing. As I said at the
start, not all small cap stocks are
growth stocks, but many people use small
cap investing as their entree into
growth investing. So there are three
basic questions I would like to examine
in this session. First, does investing
in small cap stocks generate higher
returns especially after adjusting for
risk than investing in large cap stocks?
Then I'm going to follow up and say, are
those higher returns compensation for
taking risks? You can't see risks that
don't get captured by traditional risk
measures and can you generate those
excess returns you see on paper in
practice and if there are excess returns
have there been changes over time to
those excess returns so let's start by
looking at small cap stocks before I get
embark on this process I want to
emphasize that at least in finance when
we talk about small companies we don't
talk about small companies in terms of
revenues or earnings we talk about small
companies companies in terms of market
cap, in terms of the market value
attached to these companies. So, let me
start with a graph that pretty much
every finance student sees somewhere
during the course of their finance
class. In this graph, here's what I've
done. I've looked at companies
classified by market capitalization from
smallest to largest.
These categorizations are made at the
start of the every year. and then you
look at the returns you'd have made on
each class in the following year. This
graph looks at the average annual
returns across those classes.
Now you're saying why are there two
measures? Let's start with the equally
weighted portfolios. Here what you do is
you find the 300 smallest market cap
companies put an equal amount. What's
the alternative? You could take the 300
smallest companies and invest in
proportion their market cap. We'll talk
about why there might be a difference
and what the difference tells us. But
look at the equally weighted portfolio.
You can see that there's a massive
difference between the smallest and the
largest stocks. In fact, the smallest
companies
on a on an equally weighted basis earn
close to 25%. The largest companies earn
about 11% on an annual basis. That's a
14% premium. The premium continues even
when I use value weightings, but it's
smaller. The smallest companies, if you
created value weighted portfolios, have
returns of about 18%. And the largest
companies have returns about 11 to 12%.
There's a difference, but it's not as
big. Now, you say, what does the
difference tell us? It tells us that
there's a small cap effect. It's
actually greatest in the smallest
companies in the portfolio rather than
in the larger companies, even in the
small in the smallest desile. File that
away because we're going to come back
and talk about it. But let's take a
deeper look at this small cap
phenomenon. This has been something that
finance documented starting in the
1970s. It's called the small cap premium
and it's driven a lot of practice in
valuation. For instance, people often
attach a small cap premium in estimating
a discount rate for small companies.
If you take that small cap premium and
you take the smallest and the largest
cells and you take the difference and
you graph it over time, this is the
small cap premium on an annual basis.
Here's the first thing that jumps out at
you. It's volatile. Small caps don't
beat large cap stocks every single year.
In fact, there are periods of history
where small cap stocks lag large cap
stocks, but over the entire time period,
small cap stocks deliver higher returns.
So here I've looked at both the premium
for small the smallest decile over the
market that's a red line and the premium
over the largest cap stocks and you see
the same phenomenon kick in. So it's
volatile over time. Here's the second
aspect of the small cap premium. We
talked about this earlier when we talked
about temporal price patterns. Almost
the entire small cap premium over
thatund almost 100year period has come
in one month of the year January. In
fact, if you take January's, you can see
that small cap stocks significantly
outperform large cap stocks. But you
look at the rest of the year, they look
very similar. Whatever it is that causes
the small cap premium seems to be
isolated to January.
There's also the underlying question,
which is, is this really an excess
return or is this a payment for risk
that you're taking on when you invest in
small companies? You're saying what if I
risk adjust the returns using betas?
Even then the small cap premium
persists. But the question is do bas
capture the risk of small cap stocks?
Because there are at least two issues
that people face with small cap stocks
that lead them to believe that they
should earn a higher return. The first
is estimation risk. What does that mean?
When you value a company, you face the
risk that you could be wrong on your
estimates. That risk is greater with
small cap companies because you have
less of a supporting cast. What I mean
by that is when you invest a large cap
company, there might be dozens of
analysts tracking the company and you
can look at what they're forecasting and
it helps you make your forecast. You
might not have that available with large
cap with small cap companies. In fact,
as an extended point, the fact that you
have fewer people looking at these
companies might mean that there's less
information in general available about
small companies and you're saying, "Hey,
that explains it. That's why I need to
earn a higher return." Now, I'm going to
push back a little on that phenomenon.
It is true that if you take an
individual small company and an
individual large company, that
individual small company, you face more
estimation risk, less information.
But remember, as an investor, you're not
forced to own one company. You can own a
portfolio. You're saying, "So what?" If
I take a 100 small companies and 100
large companies, it turns out that the
standard deviation of those portfolios
are not that different. You're saying,
"How can that be? If the small companies
are riskier, how come a portfolio of
small companies is not riskier as well?"
Because the risk is estimation risk or
information not being available. It
averages out across a portfolio. So the
first push back might be while
individual small cap stocks might be
riskier on a portfolio basis small cap
stocks are not that much more risky than
large cap stocks. It is true that there
are fewer analysts fewer people tracking
small cap stocks. In this graph I look
at the average number of analysts based
on large cap midcap small cap and micro
cap companies and especially in the
really small companies only about 20%
get tracked by analysts. Many of these
companies when you try to invest in
them, you will find no support with an
equity research report or analyst
projections, you might not think you're
losing much, but it it's still scarier
as an investor when there's nobody else
tracking the company.
So, the small cap cost companies
historically have earned a high return.
Much of that has come in January.
And it m you know while the return some
people can argue is is compensation for
higher risk. It turns out that
portfolios of small cap companies are
not that much more risky than portfolios
of large companies.
There's also a problem of execution.
Much of the research on small cap
premiums comes from research on paper
where researchers look at data and they
assume you can buy at the prices in the
computer database and sell at those
prices and generate those returns. It
turns out that replicating the small cap
premium is tough to do even if you're an
index fund investing these companies.
But simply, let's suppose you create an
index fund to do exactly what those
graphs you saw a few pages ago did,
which is to invest in the smallest
companies. All you do is you don't do
any research. You pick the 300 smallest
companies, you put your put your money
on them. There there was a fund called
the DFA small cap fund, you know, which
essentially tried to do this, and it was
a pretty successful fund, but it found
that its returns were lower than the
returns you saw on paper. There's an
execution and a trading cost which we
might not be capturing with those paper
portfolios and that shouldn't surprise
you. It is true that the transactions
cost for investing in smaller companies
is higher higher bid assets many are
lower priced and maybe a bigger price
impact if you're a larger portfolio. So
you could argue that while small cap
stocks good look good on paper, the
actual returns you're going to earn are
going to be lower. They still might be
good enough for you to invest in
[clears throat] them, but you got to
factor that into your decision process.
So, small cap stocks historically have
earned a higher return. But as you saw
on a year-to-year basis that small cap
pre premium was volatile. So, here's an
add-on. If you truly believe there's a
small cap premise, the data suggests
that you can it's large enough to cover
your risk and your execution costs.
There's one more caveat I would like to
add to the process. To earn that
premium, you need a longer time horizon.
In fact, in this graph, here's what I've
looked at. I've looked at small cap
versus large cap stocks and the
percentage of the time small cap that
small cap portfolio wins as a function
of your time horizon. If your time
horizon is one year,
your chance of winning is barely above
50%. If it's 2 years, it improves a tiny
bit. 3 years, it starts to jump. By the
time you get to 10, 15, 20 years, you
see a small cap premium dominate. So
even if you believe there's a small cap
premium, it turns out that you will need
to have a long time horizon to be able
to generate the returns you thought you
could make. So that's a that that that
brings home the importance of longtime
horizon. So let's summarize. Even if you
believe there's a small cap premium
based on the data, if you're a small cap
investor, it becomes far more critical
to be disciplined and diversified than
if you're a large cap investor. So if
you're large cap investor, you might get
away owning 10 large cap stocks. With
small cap stocks, you might need 20 or
25 stocks. You need more diversification
and you need more discipline
because you might need to hold the stock
through some bad time periods to be able
to generate those returns.
Second, if you're a small cap investor,
a great deal of the responsibility for
collecting information and doing your
due diligence rests on you. You can't
fall, you know, ride on the backs of
equity research analysts to do this due
diligence for you. And third, you need a
long time horizon.
So, if those things hold at least for
much of the last century as a small cap
investor, you'd have run ahead of large
cap investors.
But if you track the small cap premium
over time, something significant seems
to be happening. So to do this, here's
what I did. I took that data from 1927
through 2024 and I looked to see what
would happen to the small cap premium if
I started the data in 1927, 28, 29, 30.
In other words, I kept moving the
starting date to see what happened to
the small cap premium.
And as I kept moving the starting date,
the small cap premium started shrinking.
So if I started in 1945 instead of 1927,
you can see and I've reported both the
equally weighted and the value weighted.
The small cap premium persists, but it's
much smaller than it was if I started in
1927. The small cap premium is drifting
down over time. And in fact, there seems
to be a tipping point in the 1970s.
If I start estimating the small cap
premium in 1977,778,79
80, it turns out that the small cap
premium pretty much disappears. Think
about that. There is a small cap premium
go back all the way to 1927, but there
hasn't been one for almost 50 years, for
the last 47 years.
Sometimes in investing, we do things
because it's always been done. In this
case with the small cap premium there is
a strong argument to be made that it's
not just become more volatile recently
but that much of it has dissipated.
Jeremy Seagull in his um in his book on
stocks went in the long term argues that
a lot of the small cap premium can be
attributed in 1970s that I inflation
period and it is entirely possible that
the small cap premium has dissipated.
Now, if you're wondering why that might
be happening, part of it might be a
shifting in the market micro structure.
In 1965 or 1970, actually trading a
small cap stocks was much more expensive
than it is today. Maybe collecting
information in 1970 in small cap stocks.
I I'm not even sure how you'd have done
it. Would you have written to the
company for an annual report? Now you
can get the data on small cap stocks,
the smallest cap stocks if you have
access to a large database. The question
of whether it's an excess return or a
risk mismeasurement has persisted. Maybe
small cap stocks are riskier than we
think they are. And clearly it's
weakened over time.
Now in addition to having index funds,
you have ETFs of small cap stocks. If
you truly believe that there is still a
small cap premium, there are easier ways
for you to exploit it than it used to
be. And maybe by making it easier to
exploit, we're driving it out. So let's
summarize. If you look at the 20th
century, clearly small cap stocks earned
higher returns than large cap stocks
after adjusting risk using traditional
risk measures. And even after you
broaden the additional trading cost, you
could argue that it have earned a
premium, a higher return from adding
small cap stocks. That small cap premium
seems to have faded over the last four
or five decades. Maybe because of
changes in the marketplace. But if you
still believe there's a small cap
premium, it's far easier to try to
exploit it now because you have more
choices on exploiting it. I hope you
found this session useful and I thank
you very much for listening.